why don't we have
a rapid at-home test so you said there's
a bit of confusion
fda is involved you've talked about you
continue to talk about
that
the these at-home tests are classified
as i guess medical devices that's right
and so because of that fda is looking at
them differently
then they probably should be looked at
so
what what's the problem here can you can
you sort of explain what does it mean to
be a medical device why is that an issue
where is the fda messing up
when we declare something as a medical
device and we evaluate as a medical
device then it makes sense that the
comparison if you're trying to get a new
one onto the market
that the comparison would be against a
gold standard medical device for that
purpose
so pcr
is currently the gold standard or at
least
in
the in the eyes of the fda the pcr test
is the gold standard
uh medical device
and as a physician that's because it's
so sensitive
as a physician i have one patient in
front of me at a time
and that patient comes to me and i don't
have to care about the 99.9999
of people in the world who are not
in front of me i only care about that
one patient and so when i get a sample
from that patient and that patient's
saying doc
you know i don't feel well i haven't
been feeling well for the last few weeks
do you think this is covered
well for that question i want to have
the absolute best sensitivity test
regardless of what it means for
transmissibility because my patient
isn't sitting in my office saying doc do
you think i'm infectious
they're saying doc do you think i have
recently been or am infected
and these are totally different things
one
is medicine
and if the patient's infected you know i
the time isn't of the essence because
they're sitting there in my office i can
say look
i'm sorry you're not feeling well let's
get a pcr test on you we'll be able to
tell you if you have any
evidence that there has been recently an
infection inside of you
and you'll get the result in a couple
days
and it might be expensive and so
insurance is going to pay for it and
you're just one person and so i don't
really care how many resources it takes
to get you this answer
on the other hand
there's rapid there's public health
testing and public health testing is
it has to account for all of the people
you're not seeing as well as the person
you're testing at the moment so
accessibility becomes a central theme
frequency of tests it has to account for
all the days that you're not sitting
there in front of your doctor's office
getting a test as well as the one you
are so it has to say how frequently what
if you're infected tomorrow but you're
at the doctor's office today getting a
negative covet test
that pcr test at the doctor's office
today is going to do nothing
to let you know that you get exposed and
infected tomorrow the only way to know
that is to be testing yourself
frequently
so
and the reason it matters is
that these tests can be accessible if we
are okay with saying the real purpose of
a of a
public health test is to answer the
question am i infectious
the reason we want to answer that is if
you're infectious that's when you
isolate
we actually don't want to isolate
positive pcr pcr-positive individuals
who are no longer infectious
that's bad public health practice like
if i haven't been infectious for three
weeks i don't want to have somebody tell
me that i need to
go and isolate for 10 days just because
i happen to use a pcr test
today three weeks after i was infectious
and furthermore i definitely don't want
the public health agency to come and you
know round up all the people i was with
last night and so you guys have to
quarantine for 14 days because you were
with michael who wasn't infectious
yesterday it's nonsensical to do that
it's a huge disincentive to actually get
tested that's exactly right a huge
disincentive to get tested people you
know if it's too sensitive especially
with flights things like that like we
shouldn't be stopping people from taking
a flight if they haven't been infectious
for 60 days and to be clear
people are only infectious for somewhere
between three and seven days
but can be positive on a pcr test for
30 to 70 days
so i mean it's it's potentially a
tenfold difference in terms of how long
your pc are positive
versus how long you're infectious
so we don't want to be taking people
during those 30 to 70 days and saying
you need to isolate just because you go
and get a swab or you can't go on your
trip just because you had covered last
month
that's not good use of a test
so the reason we don't have these tools
right now is because
when we evaluate an ant a rapid test as
a medical device
the fda says
well this has to achieve the properties
that we expect from a medical device
which again
doesn't have to take time into account
doesn't really have to take cost or
resources or scalability or access into
account it only takes sensitivity and
specificity to catch
molecules and so just
by definition i mean it is a
mathematical fact you know that that if
you have a perfect public health test
for covid which means that it would be
100 sensitive
and 100 specific
for contagious people
or for the infectious stage of an
infection
then it literally can't it is an
impossibility for that test to achieve
an 80 sensitivity at a population level
against a medical device which is what
the fda asks for and that's because
you're only infectious for maybe 20
so
theoretically it should only have a 20
sensitivity
against the pcr while still being a
perfect medical a perfect public health
test and the test is answering the
question am i infectious that's what
you're testing for not for the exact
counting of the viron particles in your
system that's that's exactly right
you